I said you know what I keep seeing
online is and not even online just in in
people people people gotta stop
you know girls actually girl this is a
girl thing only girls do this you got to
stop talking about how Elon Musk is
husband material
okay not because he's not but because
that's like saying Jesus Christ saved
people okay
oh dude oh really Oh
Elon Musk is husband material
to you in a [ __ ] one-bedroom
apartment cooking [ __ ] steak comes at
4:30
cuz you woke up at 1:00 oh dude hey oh
really
rocket building you on musk genius
world-changing somehow
hair grower that [ __ ] was bald
to twelve years ago he is
Oh silly anair Elon Musk is husband
material to you and your [ __ ] duplex
husband material you don't deserve to
say yo dude really
Elon Musk is husband material oh really
hey I wonder [ __ ] why that [ __ ]
drives me up a wall you pizza
[ __ ] you [ __ ] cat owning
[ __ ] you know what I'm talking
about
that's husband material right there in
the meantime this guy's working everyday
to save the [ __ ] planet [ __ ]
and you're trying on outfits the [ __ ] go
north to the [ __ ] northeast spot in
Canada you [ __ ] Kudus Oh Elon Musk is
husband material Jesus Christ save
people and [ __ ] Sammy Davis jr. had a
glass eye what the [ __ ] else can I find
out on Wikipedia husband material dude
[ __ ] out of here why so you could take
half well you want half a rocket were
you trying to go where air is thinner
[ __ ] out of here dude for real show us a
watch on Instagram but secretly show us
your [ __ ] cleavage can't wait to [ __ ]
where my new watch Thanks tits out
[ __ ] Photoshop hips out waist in can't
wait look at the new ring I got by the
way check out MMD's you're trying to go
with the airs thinner [ __ ] off dude Elon
Musk is husband material
you think [ __ ] Elon Musk doesn't know
that [ __ ] is he sink by the way he knows
it so much he's single he's not married
he's he married he's got kids he's
married
okay you know what
who gives a [ __ ] if he's married or not
doesn't matter you know why you got the
same amount chance of [ __ ] Oh Elon Musk
his husband hero that really drove me
that drive me up a YCL all the time just
[ __ ] put in the search bar Elon Musk
husband-material
on Twitter it'll be like a [ __ ]
groceries it'll be like a [ __ ] Rite
Aid receipt this [ __ ] just coming out
it'll be like the masks tongue when he
sees [ __ ] Cameron Diaz for the first
time act act act act act across the
table musk is three times divorced Wow
same girl twice Oh what is it twenty
billion dollars net worth dude that's
weird that a twenty guy with twenty
billion dollars you think is [ __ ]
husband material uh these [ __ ]
[ __ ] you know
and remarried Andrey divorce how about
getting divorced and then being like you
know how many times that guy's [ __ ]
that guy should just get nevermind
tattooed on his forehead or no around
his ring finger we want to get married
never mind
let's get divorced never mind let's get
married never mind let's get divorced
that guy [ __ ] it that guy will do
whatever he wants I mean he makes
Rockets he's the [ __ ]
but people say that that's the whole
thing man that that [ __ ] herd
mentality that we have man is especially
online it's just like somebody says
something and then all of a sudden
that's what it was with pizza somebody
[ __ ] said uh pizzas the best some
[ __ ] skinny model said I love pizza
and then all the girls jumped on the
bandwagon like how great is pizza I eat
it all the time because they wanted to
seem like a [ __ ] normal person when
you know they're throwing it the [ __ ] up
oh yeah you're eating pizza like [ __ ]
biles not shooting out of your goddamn
face thirty minutes later and then and
then and then it got so [ __ ] rampant
that these [ __ ] beta [ __ ]
dudes are like I love my pizza go [ __ ]
out of here man get the [ __ ] out of here
beta do it your own thing man how much
do I like pizza and now let me tell you
something pizza is [ __ ] so good dude
but it's not cute to talk about it
online anymore ah
Elon Musk is husband material go [ __ ]
eat pizza man
go [ __ ]
Pizza Goku eat pizza we go eat half of
Elon Musk's pizza hmm ah
and the same girl that be like Elon Musk
is husband material will be the same
[ __ ] girl seven years into the
marriage just like all he does is work
on his Rockets all he does is work in
his Rockets he ignores me I want romance
you know mmm and then they'd [ __ ] some
guy with a long coat